[Music]
He got my women disrespected
[Music] And those who said
no started saying no and he got it done by stemming [
Music] He got it done [Music]
My name is Chandra Umar, age is 84, I
am Saheb Shooter [Music] First time in mare  I was 65 years old,
I took a gun and shot it with a bullet and it
hit the ton. I was very happy in my heart
but my family was scared.
In our village, women do
not like to go out, they like to create chaos in the house,
sir, shooting.  I don't like it, it
also has its own caution, brother, if someone comes to play with us, if there
is any danger, we can open fire
[music]
Brother, we have won many medals, we must have
won many medals in the gym, then my family started living with consent.  You were
taunting me, you did
n't hold grudge against anyone, I didn't agree, I remained busy in my work
and as I saw, they showed dedication, they
knocked on their doors, got the girl opened and scolded
their parents for playing the game of
send the
girl and not the old grandmother, if she can do it.
Why can't we take the
last breath, I will shoot
[music]